et
bonjour amis de la casquette et du petit
chat live gold c'est quoi ça
ukulélé et qu'alors on va le poser on
prendra tout à l'heure vous avez quel
âge j'ai 24 ans qu'est ce que vous allez
chanter alors j'ai une chanson d'amour
au ukulélé qui n'ont une chose ensemble
ukulélé pour l'instant la chaîne de tri
j'en ai pas je trouvais qu une chanson
vous est prévu qu'une chanson ukulélé je
vais vous demander de repartir et vaudou
kulélé donc parce que nous on n'écoute
que les gens s'en vont financer
n'importe quoi enfin
on me croit pas à la mémoire
tu savais ta va contre l'histoire de la
tas a pris ses goûts
ok ça tout de suite
qu'est-ce qui s'est terminée en 1945
n'est pas prêt du tout bonjour
ok les amis on est lundi j - 5 samedi on
sera ou
salade de vie ça se passe samedi il
restait encore je crois les dernières
peuvent être malades andy est retransmis
sur tmc avec slimane avec des gains à
une des surprises de fait j'espère trop
lisse on a choisi les deux publics ah
ouais
[Musique]
et la raison tymoshchuk je me motivait
jeux moisis et je veux une vie où je
passe ma vie à faire des acteurs comme
ça et me regarder dans un miroir et
ferre gola jeu trop mystères et je suis
trop musclée oui c'est du muscle qui va
disparaître le jour où je m'arrête pas
ce que c'est que la gonflette mais oh là
là c'est trop bien oh mon dieu un pot de
protéines ozitem au délicieux pour eux
je mange idées des autres contes et des
frites et des apéros avec mes copains où
avait joué à tête s'est passé dans la
vraie vie vraie vie c'est ça c'est mon
jus de prod nous regarder le monde
miroir et faire un moment dieu que ce
que je suis musclée tiens je me rappel
thor the mèdes du saindoux comme ça je
brille voilà c'est ça la vraie vie et à
la raison et ébauches chef c'est à dire
un coup les amis c'est nul de revoir les
moments de convivialité c'est nous c'est
pas mieux de faire développé couché bah
si